vim de um lugar bem desconhecido uma
fronteira mas ao mesmo tempo um paraíso
um paraíso que está na sua atmosfera um
arco cheio de sonhos sonhos que parece
loucura aos olhos daqueles que o vivem
crescer sonhar em me ver saber de onde
vim mas não saber para onde vou
assim são com todos aqueles que sabem
que o universo é vasto
mas que também sabe que as oportunidades
não são limitadas quando sonha grande
olá boa tarde eu me chamo clara santos
vaze a minha vida tomou diversos mundos
para que hoje eu estivesse aqui falando
um pouquinho da minha história com vocês
tudo começou em 2000 quando eu nasci na
cidade de araputanga uma das cidades do
interior aqui do estado de mato grosso e
com um ano de idade foi morar com os
meus pais na cidade de porto esperidião
eu cresci ali e como o crescimento eu
sempre ouvi falar que eu tinha que ser
alguém quando eu crescesse e se será
alguém quando eu crescer para fazer uma
faculdade e eu sempre quis estudar coisa
que para muitas pessoas talvez seja
normal inter diante estudar pra mim era
um sonho eu estava super empolgado
queria que esse dia chegasse bem
passaram seis anos e esse dia chegou
lembro muito bem que eu calçava sapatos
da minha mãe e colocar um livro debaixo
do braço dizia mamãe eu vou ser a
advogada quando crescer e ali passaram
se os anos eu estudando entrar no ensino
médio no primeiro ano e eu sempre senti
que eu deveria fazer algo diferente
começando fazendo a diferença na minha
família
cresci vendo meu pai passar muita
dificuldade em lutar bastante para que
nós não passamos esse
a rádio ea minha mãe sempre disse que o
estudo era tudo que eu tinha por que o
conhecimento é algo que ninguém tira da
gente então eu me propus a não perder
nenhuma oportunidade que fosse mudada
quando se tratasse de realizar o meu
sonho de estudo de fazer uma boa
faculdade
foi quando a vida me lançam o primeiro
desafio o desafio de sair da minha casa
saí do meu conforto sair do do meu colo
de mãe enfrentar o mundo em 2016 quando
eu tinha 15 anos e uma tia me convidou
para morar com ela em tangará da serra
naquele momento eu me vem tendo que
tomar uma decisão que mudaria minha vida
mas ao mesmo tempo teria de sair da área
de conforto mas como eu disse eu não
poderia deixar as oportunidades passar
dependentes da fifa os enganos ou
enfrentar o desafio porque o medo medo
existia dentro de mim mas não era maior
que os meus sonhos que a minha força de
conquistar o meu sonho
foi então que eu mudei em fevereiro de
2016 para tangará da serra
comecei a morar com a minha tia e lá eu
não tava muito pra conseguir manter na
escola nova com o ensino diferente é
fazendo cursinho sentando pelo aquilo
que eu queria que era realmente pegar
aquele tempo que eu tinha e depositar
aquilo que eu não tinha conhecimento com
falta de oportunidade
então foi o que eu fiz passou-se alguns
meses eu já não me via mais aquela
menina de 17 anos que não sabia nem
ligar um computador porque é onde eu
morava não tinha essa tecnologia então
não sabia nem que quer o internet para
que servia
agora eu estava diferente eu estava
clara que estava dentro do grêmio
estudantil da minha escola eu era
secretária geral eu estava aprendendo
muitas coisas nó
e eu tinha uma visão uma visão de quando
a gente faz o caminho com um objetivo
quando você treina esse caminho você vai
descobrir coisas novas que vai fazer com
que você mude muito o pensamento de
vocês eu saí de casa com o plano de
fazer uma faculdade ajudar os pais e
depois de alguns meses eu já não não via
mas somente fazendo a faculdade dos meus
pais não via já diferente as minhas
ideias foram acrescentadas por um
conhecimento
então eu vi um ambiente de oportunidades
estendidos na minha frente e eu queria
abraçá lo cada vez mais transformar em
realidade na minha vida
só que no final de 2016 recebeu no dia
ruim
a minha tia me disse que eu não poderia
mais morar com ela porque o meu
relacionamento com meu tio não estava
muito bom ea situação financeira dela
também não tava muito legal
então ela falou clara eu gostaria muito
de continuar ajudando mas a tia não pode
naquele momento vive em tristeza
desânimo porque meus sonhos enterrados
vivos
eu não tenho um ano dos que é e de
repente aquilo que eu estava mais que
encaminhada teria dado o pontapé inicial
para começar minha carreira estava
desmoronando porque se eu voltasse
interino que servia de geninho o que
seria de mim
voltando por um lugar sem oportunidades
só que quando eu menos esperava aparecer
uma luz no fim do turno o que foi essa
luz no fim do túnel
essa luz foi com a minha tia que mora em
cuiabá outra tia me convidou pra falar
pra morar com ela falou pra mim claro eu
não tenho muita coisa mas eu tenho a
minha casa e eu quero te receber da
maneira que eu posso até você se
estabilizar
eu acredito que no ano de 2008 você vai
ter entrado no universo
então você vai conseguir continuar sua
vida sozinha quando ela falou aqui não
vi que a vida estava empregando segundo
desafio mudar de outra cidade começar
tudo de novo e eu falei que sou capaz
nosso cuiabá mas mas cuiabá eu nunca fui
cuiabá
como que eu vou conseguir superar esses
limites
só que o medo era grande só com a
vontade continuarei a maior ainda
então eu vi iniciei meus estudos e
continua sendo clara de sempre
porém como eu tinha dito é a vida quando
você trilha um caminho de objetivos de
encarrega de mostrar novos oriente
diante disso eu conheci na minha escola
professores do projeto chamado ensino
brasil um projeto que é voltado para
mudar a educação pública é nas
metodologias das maneiras de agir em
sala de aula eu tinha três professores
na minha escola e um deles era meu
professor de história e quando eu vi que
tinha pessoas que lutava pela sociedade
melhor por um mundo melhor
eu me identifiquei porque apesar de tudo
o que eu vivi eu tomo tudo como
experiência porque isso foi abrindo a
minha visão de mundo
quando eu vim pra cuiabá já não via mais
um mundo tão simples
eu tinha outra visão de mundo eu queria
uma sociedade melhor eu queria trabalhar
para que isso acontecesse eu queria
fazer algo diferente para mudar o meu
mundo começando pelo meio de rodovia
só que como eu disse eu não sabia como
fazer isso
naquele momento quando eu encontrei
pessoas que já faziam isso eu me senti
em poderá dá pra fazer acontecer
foi quando eu não tenho o meu projeto
restaurando vidas um projeto que
consistia em trabalhar a autoestima dos
alunos trabalhar direito
a sociedade os direitos humanos
consistia em fazer com que os alunos
aplicassem o tempo deles é na educação e
no conhecimento e no começo e passei por
várias etapas de montagem eu fui apoiada
pelos professores inclusive pelo meu
professor que tinha me contado sobre
projetos no brasil que inspirou montei
um projecto lei na coordenação da escola
e passaram uma semana
a coordenadora da escola me chega com o
caderno de esclareceu projeto foi
aprovado
esse será o seu diário de aula toda a
sua metodologia eu sou a carga horária
material que você precisa a gente pode
fornecer
então vai lá e aplica o seu projeto que
a gente quer ver a diferença
trabalhei com 15 alunos nesse projeto um
projeto onde eu apliquei aos direitos
humanos
os alunos foram lindo foram é
trabalhando metodologias para melhorar o
comportamento de outros alunos
esses alunos foi selecionado com
professores professores que já conheciam
ele sala de aula sabe que ele não era
muito fácil no começo que eu apliquei
esse projeto eu escutava muitas coisas
mas muitas coisas por exemplo esses
meninos não tem jeito clara você acha
que você pode mudar o mundo se eu fosse
você e cuidaria da sua vida e deixaria
de mão por aqui não vai dar nada você
vai perder seu tempo de dar o enem então
eu vi que tinha muitas coisas que me
entristeceu nas palavras das pessoas mas
eu não tava ali trabalhando pela aquilo
que as pessoas iam falar de mim eu
estava ali trabalhando porque eu queria
a diferença naqueles alunos porque eu
acreditava verdadeiramente que eles
tinham uma solução e só precisavam ser
direcionados e foi quando eu menos
esperava esse meu professor de história
me falou que através da aplicação dos
direitos humanos no meu projeto teria
como seria com a conferência é da
juventude na luta pelos direitos humanos
em nova york e ele falou vou te escrever
clara só que
espero que você esteja na expectativa
mas não tem tantos porque é possível
como é possível você participar dessa
conferência
o primeiro passo é fazer a inscrição a
gente vai realizar porque no ano
anterior ele tinha participado dessa
conferência
então ele falou eu gostaria muito que
você participasse
ele inscreveu e passaram se alguns dias
chegou um e mail que dizia que eu estava
convidado a participar dessa conferência
tinha um convite estendido à minha
pessoa eu fiquei muito surpresa porque
quando eu montei o projeto não pensei
que ia atrás nações unidas não era esse
o meu objetivo
então começaram os preparativos não
tinha dinheiro e não tinha recursos
financeiros para fazer essa viagem com
melhoria viajar passagem hospedagem uma
série de coisas o passaporte eo visto
mas talvez aos meus olhos aquilo era uma
barreira mas aos olhos das pessoas que
estavam transitando nos meus sonhos não
era uma barreira porque é clara porque
eu fui apoiada por um time um grupo de
pessoas que lutaram para que até o
último instante essa viagem desse certo
foram feitos marquinhos online que faz
na escola os professores desse projeto
em si no brasil me ajudaram os
professores da escola inclusive os 140
municípios do estado de mato groso de
alguma maneira ajudar porque ela vá kio
online com estava verdadeiramente que
eles tinham ajudado que seja um real mas
eles tinham ajudado e eu me sentir feliz
ea conferência ocorrerá de 24 25 e 26 de
agosto dia 21 de agosto de 2017
ali estava eu embarcando no meu primeiro
vôo internacional
eu não esperava e foi quando eu caí na
seguinte reflexão
quando a gente trabalha para melhor do
mundo que a gente vive
quando a gente trabalha pela melhoria da
sociedade mas acima de tudo quando a
gente trabalha por algo
nós acreditamos sem querer nada em troca
sem esperar nada em troca simplesmente o
que você espera ver o resultado
a vida se encarrega de abrir as portas
das oportunidades pra você e pra mim e
ali eu me vi diante dessa oportunidade
foi aberta que não era o meu objetivo
até então
e mais uma vez eu vi como a vida
generosa quando a gente luta e essa
viagem minha foi o terceiro desafio que
a vida me deu porque eu não sabia falar
inglês
eu não tinha condição financeira mas eu
fui lá e representar o meu país
representando o estado do meu projeto lá
nas nações unidas em nova york
falei meu discurso em inglês com muita
dificuldade mas eu consegui e voltei com
a inspiração de transformar mais e mais
a mesma ea minha sociedade as pessoas
que estão à minha volta
então hoje eu vejo a vida como feita de
superar limites e alcançar sonhos não
importa se a sua atitude seja de mudar
uma vida mudar uma vida mudar muita
coisa o que importa é você começar a
mudança através de você mesmo quando
você gera uma mudança dentro de si
você vai começar a gerar mudança no
outro aí onde entra aquela frase não
espero no outro a mudança que tem que
partir de você tem que partir de mim e
hoje mesmo tempo apenas 17 anos eu tenho
orgulho de ter aprendido tudo isso eu
tenho muito orgulho de ter aprendido que
ninguém pode determinar quem você é se
você determinar o que você quer
eu digo a vocês queridos sentem
desafiados a fazer a diferença no mundo
de hoje e no mundo de amanhã mas acima
de tudo se sintam desafiados a realizar
seus sonhos
aliás
foi a última vez que vocês vão tocar um
som de verdade não importa ele sendo
grande ou pequeno aos teus olhos o que
importa é dar o primeiro passo e fazer
acontecer
as dificuldades existem sim existem mas
elas existem para ser superadas por isso
agora eu vou respeitar aquela poesia que
eu criei para iniciar e hoje aqui eu
adiciono uma frase a ela uma frase que a
vida me ensinou e ela vai ficar o
seguinte vitor lugar bem desconhecido
uma fronteira mas ao mesmo tempo um
paraíso um paraíso cheio de vida e isola
na atmosfera um arco cheirinho de sonhos
sonhos que parecem loucura aos olhos
daqueles que vivem saber de onde vim mas
não saber para um vôo assim são com
todos aqueles que sabe que o universo é
vasto
mas que também sabe que as oportunidades
não são limitadas
quando se sonha grande então a frase que
eu adiciono agora então realizar é
questão de tempo
então realizar os seus sonhos a realizar
as suas metas
queridas é questão de tempo luti
acredite e faça acontecer
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]